[Music]
our city is some
four days ago in Calabasas
nine lives were lost leaving a gaping
hole in the heart of Los Angeles we
gather tonight in the house that Kobe
Bryant do to honor him and then
COBE was a synonymous for Southern
California as the sunshine
he touched every inch of it he arrived
in LA a prodigy to a phenomenon and
retired a local institution an
international icon the outpouring of the
past 96 hours is evidence of his
everlasting impact whether he played for
your team or kissed it
his allure was unmistakable the dynamism
the determination the drive he won five
championships with the Lakers and
shortly after unfurling his final
fadeaway earned an Academy Award he was
a storyteller a mentor in above all a
father
his 13 year old daughter Gianna was a
basketball star her all right
join us in tribute to Kobe GG and all
the victims worn throughout the
Southland and across the globe Orange
Coast College baseball coach John
Altobelli his wife Kari and their
daughter Alyssa Sarah Chester and her
daughter Payton Marvel Academy
basketball coach Christina Mouser in
Pilot arizo line
[Music]
[Applause]